armenia's prime minister nicole
pashinyan
beating the troops on monday in
nagorno-karabakh
a mountainous patch of land azerbaijani
under international law
populated mostly by ethnic armenians and
claimed by both countries
the war they fought as the soviet union
collapsed looks in danger of repeating
itself but with an entirely new
dimension
the armenian prime minister tells sky
news
what we are facing is an azerbaijani
turkish
international terroristic attack on
nagorno-karabakh
and i think this is not any longer a
purely local issue look
france acknowledged that there are
mercenaries terrorists who were brought
in from syria the islamic republic of
iran confirmed it
russian federation confirmed it
russia and france said they were
concerned that reports of mercenaries
being on the line some turkey and
azerbaijan deny that turkey also denies
being actively involved militarily but
what president alief has said
is that he wants to see negotiations
with turkey at the negotiating table is
that something that you would accept
of course not because in the
negotiations
we need to have actors which are keen
on settlement of the conflict and not
deepening the conflict
turkey's foreign minister traveled to
meet the azerbaijani president today
to further an alliance that armenia's
prime minister claims represents an
existential threat for his people
it is absolutely not inflammatory
language when i say that
this is turkey's
policy to continue the armenian genocide
let us look at what turkey is
implementing in the mediterranean in
libya in syria iraq
to me there is no doubt that this
is a policy of continuing the armenian
genocide
and a policy of reinstating the turkish
empire
with the azerbaijanis parading video of
abandoned armenian positions nicole
passion admits that the fighting is
tough
but he offers no alternatives
we need first of all the essence of what
is happening to be acknowledged
in the sense that azerbaijan
initiated an attack a military offensive
against
despite the fact that
the international community have clearly
stated that the use of force or threat
of force
is impermissible
in the context of settling issues
for now force prevails settling the
nagorno-karabakh
issue as elusive now as it ever was
dynamagne sky news eurovan armenia